in the place beyond the pines ryan
gosling plays a stunt motorcyclist
covered in tattoos often very sweaty and
usually wearing a white tank top I could
actually feel the estrogen level and my
feet are just exploding the place beyond
the pines is a film I saw at TIFF last
weekend it's from the director of Blue
Valentine also starring Gosling I always
wish that I had seen this in 2010
because it would have been one of my
favorite films of the year and I was so
excited to see this movie because there
was no release date for it there was no
synopsis released I knew nothing there
was no trailers nothing I went in 100%
blind not knowing a single thing about
this movie and man did it ever pay off
now for those who are weary of spoilers
don't worry I'm not gonna spoil a thing
my description of this film is gonna be
as minimal as possible because I want
you to go in with as less knowledge as
possible because I think to truly savor
this film you have to do that because it
is such an unpredictable movie so as I
said Ryan Gosling is a stunt
motorcyclist you know he rides through
the sphere of death those metal cages
where motorcycles go in circles and
circles and everything and people watch
Eva Mendes plays this old flame that is
reintroduced into his life and he's
dealt some news by her that makes him
question whether or not he wants to
continue this lifestyle he's living and
it leads him down kind of dark paths
Bradley Cooper plays a city cop who kind
of gets intertwined in this story as
well and he starts making some bad
decisions some poor choices and Dane
DeHaan the kid from Chronicle and
lawless he plays a young kid in school
who's kind of troubled he's
contemplating a life of crime that's all
I'm gonna say cuz as far as I know this
movie may not come out until next year
awards season this was the best film I
saw it if this year there was not one
thing about this movie I was able to
predict and this day it's still burning
in my mind despite the fact that it was
one of the first films I saw it TIFF
Gosling is on fire in this movie you
cannot take your eyes off him his
performance this guy is good ok this is
a good actor he's an actor who's clearly
just avoiding all that whole Hollywood
machine system thing and going for these
roles that actually means something that
actually has something to deliver to
cinema a movie that really makes you
think about it discuss it and you can't
really relate it to any other film this
movie's wholly original but one of the
biggest surprises of this movie to me
was just how good Bradley Cooper was
this is by far the best performance I've
seen from him I've never been like a
huge fan of him I have no problem with
it I'm just I
this performance is definitely
oscar-worthy he's so great in this movie
towards the end of the film I was like
my word Bradley Cooper where have you
been such a great performance he almost
brought me to tears he really did he was
excellent excellent excellent in this
movie Young Dane DeHaan also really
impressive actor I he is definitely
going to be going places with chronical
lawless and this that I've seen all in
the same year he's been the most
impressive probably young actor I can
think of at this time this movie also
has the additions of Rose Byrne and Ray
Liotta two other actors I really enjoyed
every single actor was on the top of
their game everyone really was
delivering performances that didn't seem
as if they were planned you know they
don't feel like okay here I'm gonna do
this and I'm gonna do that they seem
like the director was just able so lucky
to capture these great moments in time
and they were so effective the
cinematography is amazing it looks so
beautiful and there's this really
chilling sense of darkness throughout
this movie even though most of the film
is bright and colorful a lot of it does
take place around a pine forest and
there's some amazing motorcycle chase
sequences as well that were just
visceral like I've never seen a chase
actually film this way I don't know what
type of camera setup he used but it blew
my mind I was just I it was incredible
there were shots in this movie where I
got goose bumps that were just so
incredibly well done and the music just
impacted you in this way that really
just made you feel like you were encased
in that pine forest one of the
underlying themes of this movie is
trying to do the right thing or set
things right in your mind perhaps going
about it in the wrong way all the major
characters in this movie experienced
that and in that way all of these
stories all interweave with one another
beautifully a lot of people have asked
me like what is it more like is it more
like Drive or is it more like Blue
Valentine is it more action II more
thrilling or suspense or is it more
drama to be honest it has all of those
in one no this is not an action film
this is very much a drama so don't go in
expecting drive to this is very much
like Blue Valentine and Drive combined
it has all the best elements of both of
those films beautiful cinematography
incredible performances but really
really human drama at the deepest levels
of human emotion there was a standing
ovation and applause at TIFF for maybe
like three or four minutes
on ending completely unceasing fantastic
film I have no idea when this film is
going to be released it will be next
year more than likely but when you get a
chance to see it do not miss it it's
definitely something to remember I'm
gonna give the place beyond the pines an
A+ so as I said that was my favorite
film of TIFF I have more views coming
very soon for Seven Psychopaths Cloud
Atlas the impossible others as well
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you like this then you can
click right here and get stuck my nice
[Music]